mosquitoes can cause many diseases like  dinghy do you know how dengue mosquito  can discriminate you versus a particular  animal let's say a cat or a dog  scientist have an answer to that they  have created a transgenic mosquito where  the brain activity can be monitored in  real time they head fix this mosquito  while they are alive they can create a  small hole in the mosquitoes head and  watch the brain in real time under a two  photon microscope they also put a puff  of odor  they found out two aldehydes present in  human only and not in other species such  as decanal and  under canal can create them max response  that means they can discriminate us  versus other animals based on these  aldehydes which are selective to human  skin  this strategy can be used to generate  efficient mosquito traps  that's one minute see you in next video